welcome to el zonte known as bitcoin
beach
this little surf town on the coast of el
salvador is one of the first to go full
crypto
yup you heard that right everything from
groceries to coffee to salaries and
community projects
can be paid for using bitcoin it's
actually been
crazy how fast it has caught on and how
useful bitcoin's been for
you know everyday people just to buy
something as simple as a cup of coffee
can be done quickly painlessly
the town of 3000 has never had a bank
now their only atm
buys and sells bitcoin and nearly 90
percent of households interact with the
currency regularly
since this video was shot el salvador
has become the first country to accept
bitcoin as legal tender
next week i will send to congress a bill
that will make bitcoin a legal tender in
el salvador but how did el salvador a
country where 70
of the population is unbanked become the
first country to use bitcoin as legal
tender
mike peterson one of the leaders at
bitcoin beach project says it all
started in 2019
when an anonymous american donor got in
touch through their evangelical
christian church
the donor wanted to remain anonymous he
didn't want any credit for things
he wants to see bitcoin used in real
ways he doesn't want to give the
organizations that are just going to
convert it to fiat
and you know they as an organization
really believe that most of the benefit
of what they're trying to do
would be by seeding bitcoin economies
throughout the world
that's when peterson drafted a plan to
create a bitcoin economy
and recruited a small staff of el zonte
residents
we had a timeline and we're at like year
three right now
when we're only you know halfway you
know 18 months into it
part of that was kind of sped up by the
the pandemic of all things
when el salvador's tourism industry and
el zonte's economy collapsed
peterson started making monthly
transfers of about 35
in bitcoin to 500 families around town
during that time you know people
couldn't
go out of their homes to work a lot of
people were starting to go hungry
and so we kind of used some of the
resources we had to
start sending bitcoin to the majority of
the families in el zante and teaching
the stores how to accept
bitcoin which helped the the stores to
be able to you know stay in business and
keep their employees
on but it also allowed the the people to
remain
fed maria del carmen the owner of a tiny
pizza eatery
says she was skeptical about storing
money on her phone
now bitcoin accounts for as much as half
of her roughly 45 dollars a day in sales
sienna
enzo rubio owner of breakpoint cafe
never thought twice about crypto until
his customers asked him about it
within the first week of his opening and
he showed me the app
we downloaded it in three minutes i had
the app
the wallet in my phone and he paid me
my first cappuccino on bitcoin
shops in town price everything in
dollars whether the underlying
transaction is in bitcoin or not
a cappuccino always costs and fifty
cents
even if bitcoin's value has just jumped
or dropped in this way
it behaves more like a token than a
currency
what was in my mind at that point was
what am i going to do with it am i
losing my money
did i give coffee for free and now
whatever i get on bitcoin is i keep it
as savings
that brings a risk of volatility into
play since mid-april bitcoin has lost
nearly half of its value
and the international monetary fund has
warned that crypto assets can post
significant risks
mike's team is preparing residents for
an extended down cycle by moving some
holdings into us dollars
or making large purchases now while
prices are high
obviously bitcoin has been trending up
during the time of this you know the
project
and we understand that might not always
be the case but we found that people
actually
they learn really quickly how to ride
volatility how
to adjust how to think you know which
funds
am i putting aside for 10 years where
i'm not really worried about it
which funds are for next week so i need
to move it into dollars to be able to
make a dollar denominated payment
and it's actually been much less of an
issue than we initially anticipated
although locals were skeptical at first
many feel saved by the implementation of
crypto in their community
a
el salvador's bitcoin law will come into
effect on september 7th
[Music]